things even gets crazy at my family
thanksgiving is one of my favorites and
this pie will always be there nobody
does it quite like we do hi my name is
erin van slotten and today i'm going to
be making my grandfather's recipe for
blueberry tapioca pie tapioca in this
recipe is being used as a thickener some
people might use cornstarch or other
ingredients but definitely in the
midwest we use tapioca this pie i
originally heard from my grandfather he
would make this pie every year for my
dad's birthday he would wake up at 6 00
am to come and bring this pie to my dad
so if we're lucky enough we'll be able
to pick fresh blueberry since michigan
is known for its wild blueberries and
everyone will hoard them for the summer
months knowing that we're going to want
them for thanksgiving
i just have to try one
you have to make sure it's good first
when i was too young to bake i would
just sit at the kitchen table and wait
until my sister or my dad or whoever
else was making it would turn their back
and i'd grab a few blueberries just in
case so usually if you have extra crusts
left over me and my sisters would take
the extra crust and cut a bee out of it
for my dad's name berry or you know also
for blueberry pie because my grandfather
would always take the crust and poke
holes in it so that it made his initials
pie is always a staple for thanksgiving
and it's a real tradition in my family
even if my sisters have all moved and
i've left we always come back for the
holidays and we know we can gather
around food and this pie will always be
there
[Music]
just like how my grandfather used to
make it
hi my name is bianca lambert and i am
cooking my aunt vivian's sweet potato
pie my aunt is the only person in our
family that still bakes sweets she's the
only person that's kind of carried this
recipe over from my grandmother and just
kind of passed down those southern roots
so the way that you will know your
potatoes are done you just kind of give
it a little poke for a little stab
that's how you know that it's ready i
grew up in atlanta and my parents are
from this town in alabama called
monroeville so thanksgiving christmas
like whatever holiday you can think of
we would drive down for my grandma i
remember like she would just always have
all this food and she didn't have a lot
of money and all that but you could
guarantee
that there was going to be a spread
everything that you ever wanted she knew
all your favorites and that was her way
of showing love and i feel like that is
what
southern cooking is all about it's just
a way to show love and and give back to
your family in a different kind of way
i'll say this i'm always looking forward
to this pie for thanksgiving and
christmas i might even volunteer to make
the sweet potato pie this year nobody's
probably gonna let me do it though or
they'll let me do like one and then
she'll do all of them
anybody makes anything good like if you
know something's really good at
thanksgiving it just goes so if you
don't get to that pie before it's gone
forget about it yeah you better get it
when you can
and people i mean we do shares very much
about community but people like what
they like
we all know each other's favorites so
yeah once it's gone
that's it this is just one of my
all-time favorites it's the thing i can
eat i mean i could eat a whole pie by
myself so my aunt surprised me by
letting me know that she uses lemon
extract in
the sweet potato pie when she said it i
was like is she making a mistake but
it's been perfect for years so i'm sure
she knows what she's talking about
here's the thing i don't think anyone
can cook sweet potato pie like anybody
in my family nobody does it quite like
we do but hey to all the aunties and
grandmas and people out there like you
guys are amazing and i just think we're
all partial to our
family's cooking thanksgiving for us is
just like the best time of the year
probably my favorite holiday just
because it's so much about family and
food and eating and just having a good
time
it tastes so good
my aunt's gonna be super proud
my name is brynden dahl and today i am
making my mom's amazing pumpkin pie it
is my favorite thing in the entire world
my mom is always the one who makes the
pies for thanksgiving 100
we are allowed in the kitchen honestly
everyone kind of congregates in the
kitchen
in part because it smells so good but
also because that's where my mom is so
and talk to her and keep her company
while she makes us delicious food this
is my grandmother's pie dough recipe so
the whole pumpkin pie recipe is actually
i say it's my mom's but really it's her
mother's it's not super complicated in
its ingredients but it's a very dense
spicy pie which i think is like maybe a
little more old-fashioned it's a very
very old family recipe
i'm from arkansas and i do feel like
pumpkin pie is popular there
but there's kind of a big division
there's pumpkin pie people and there's
pecan pie people and we say pecan not
pecan there are two distinct camps
honestly my mom makes both but the
pumpkin is like the star and the pecan
pie is for like the other folks i don't
want to imagine a life without pumpkin
pie this pumpkin pie it is a holiday
staple but honestly like living i live
across the country from my mom and our
whole family is really spread apart
so even when we go back random times
during the year like if i go back in
april i get pumpkin pie if i go back
anytime i get pumpkin pie it's
definitely the main comfort food that
like makes me feel like i'm home and
like i don't feel like i'm officially
home until i've had this pumpkin pie
regardless of what time of year it is
i would like to say that
we like chip in like oh my mom makes the
pies but like i have an amazing castle
roll or something but i i bring nothing
to the table
um literally
i like thanksgiving a lot actually i
love holidays but i'm not someone who
gets like really obsessive over holidays
but for me thanksgiving is one of my
favorites because it's so food-based
anytime you have a lot of food i'm down
to be there so thanksgiving is probably
my favorite holiday because like you
know that the meal is gonna be on point
typically i celebrate thanksgiving with
my mom um and my my brother chris if he
can make it we don't really have that
big of a family i'm in california my
brother's in texas i have another
brother in kentucky and it's just been
hard the last few years to actually get
everyone together so some years it's
just me and my mom some years it's like
you know a couple of us or a couple
extra like some cousins here and there
but we're a pretty small group making
this pie is definitely bringing back
some nostalgia because it's actually
been a couple years since i've gotten to
go home for thanksgiving i'm not sure i
realized how homesick for this pie i was
and homesick in general so this is a
nice treat
honestly of all the thanksgiving foods
really of all holiday foods regardless
of holiday this is kind of like the big
one this is the one mainstay like on
thanksgiving or christmas or whatever
sometimes we'll have like ham instead of
turkey or this instead of that but the
one thing that never changes is pumpkin
pie
oh it even smells perfect
it's the perfect pie it's absolutely
perfect
i'm ray pajar and today i'm making my
thai tea pie when i first brought the
pie out to
thanksgiving
my family was like really surprised that
you could get thai tea into a pie flavor
and since then it's just been one of
those things that my family just expects
me to bring to thanksgiving every year
so my sister-in-law will bring two
traditional pies apple or pecan or
strawberry and then i'll be in charge of
the two thai tea pies which
usually goes by
faster compared to the other pies since
again this is not something that you
would be able to get at your local pie
store thanksgiving gets crazy at my
family because it's like we're loud
there's a lot of us
with family hashtag my last name is
pahar so we had a ty so it's party
because there's so many of us that we
had a hard time getting photos whenever
we would take like a group photo or any
kind of photo during a party so we just
made the hashtag so that you could look
it up and find the photo online
but now it's just become like a fun
thing so my family came out to
california
in the 1980s the family was still
relatively small it was just my mom my
dad
my like six older half siblings and as
the years grew and as we all became
adults everyone brought something to the
table so the table just got bigger what
was originally probably close to a
traditional thanksgiving became
something that is pretty much a giant
thanksgiving party since like now we
can't really fit into one table but will
fit into one house as we all get older
everyone brings something new so if i
showed up to thanksgiving without a pie
specifically this thai tea pie they
would put me in the kitchen and make
this pie the first year that i actually
made this pie i made one thai tea pie
and then i also made an earl grey pie my
family liked the earl grey pie but it
just wasn't as
popular compared to the thai tea pie and
my family is like blunt enough that
they'll be like this is good but it's
not great could we just get two of the
thai tea pies instead of a earl grey pie
for the amount of people that we do have
over four thanksgiving someone is always
bound to forget something since i'm
traveling over there i don't really end
up forgetting a pie or anything but
there have been years where we would
forget like the lumpia someone would
forget the rice someone would forget the
mashed potatoes with big families you
have to move fast if you're going to
hope that someone's going to save you a
slice of a pie or a piece of a cake
sucks for you because not everyone's
going to say that
my favorite way to serve the thai tea
pie is to give it a nice healthy dollop
of fresh whipped cream just because it
ties it all together and it looks really
pretty
i love sharing with my family
but this one is all mine
you